[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous lundi 13 novembre début
d'une nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 78 bienvenue dans de 7,8
journal lé titre de cette édition
tu m'aimes tu me respectes slogan de la
nouvelle campagne de prévention lancée
ce matin par l'île de france elle vise à
lutter contre les violence dans les
relations amoureuses des 15-18 ans une
jeune femme sur sept a déjà subi des
violences psychologiques et psychiques
ou sexuelles samedi c'était le 99e
anniversaire de l'armistice qui a mis
fin à la première guerre mondiale des
cérémonies se tenait dans toutes les
villes de saint quentin en yvelines
nous étions à maurepas et nos deux
invités elles ont mené des recherches
sur 26 poilus et de montigny le
bretonneux pascal mathieu et patricia
poulard et puis dans ce journal retour
sur la 4e édition des smart days
organisés par la cci versailles yvelines
à guyancourt
le rendez-vous de rencontres entre les
entreprises du territoire thème cette
année les technologies du futur
16% des agressions sexuelles se déroule
entre 15 et 17 ans phénomène que
souhaite endiguer la région ile de
france
je lisais dans les titres elle a lancé
ce matin une campagne de prévention des
violences dans les relations amoureuses
chez les adolescents c'était au conseil
régional à paris devant près de 700
lycéens franciliens
nicolas landry quand je sais que j'ai
pas envie si j'ai pas envie l'âge j'ai
pas été pensé ce qu'on allait faire
toute la journée
tu m'aimes tu me respectes une campagne
de prévention des violences dans les
relations amoureuses des jeunes âgés de
15 à 17 ans des adolescents concernés
par ce phénomène certains lycéens ont
participé à l'élaboration des vidéos et
des affiches dans mon entourage dans mes
amis qui sont en couple
je vois des parfois les attitudes qui
sont un peu un peu dégradantes un peu de
possession
même des interrogations qui vont un peu
trop loin base déjà c'est de forcer
quelqu'un à faire quelque chose dont il
n'y en a pas envie par exemple va la
forcer à avoir des rapports sexuels
et ça c'est vraiment dans les cas
extrêmes mais même par exemple de
toucher une personne à des endroits par
exemple quand elle n'en a pas envie
les adolescents une population prise en
compte par le centre hubertine auclert
organisme rattaché à la région ile de
france spécialisée dans les expertises
sur l'égalité hommes femmes
sa présidente marie pierre bade réélu au
conseil régional a lancé cette campagne
pour s'est rendu compte à la suite des
enquêtes que nous avons menées que nous
n'avions pas cette tranche d'âge de 15 à
18 ans on a bien vu qu'il y avait de
vrais soucis quand on les a interrogés
notamment sur le caractère un peu
violent de la façon dont ils
s'appréhende est dans leurs relations
des affiches ont été envoyés dans tous
les lycées d'île de france
les chefs d'établissement ont la
possibilité de contacter le centre
hubertine auclert pour demander une
formation du personnel afin d'aborder le
sujet avec les élèves
si vous voulez une relation sans
consentement c'est un peu comme les
épinards quoi basse et dégueulasse
politique ce n'est pas un mais deux
ministres qui étaient dans les yvelines
vendredi dernier la ministre de la santé
agnès buzyn et celui de l'agriculture
stéphane travert se sont rendus à saint
nom la bretèche et visite sur le thème
de l'économie circulaire et de
l'alimentation saine au sein de la boîte
à champignons elle fait pousser
notamment des pleurotes monte cristo
dans du marc de café 150 à 200 kg de
champignons sont produits par
l'entreprise chaque semaine en utilisant
des procédés inédits et anti et
gaspillage alimentaire propos recueillis
par nicolas landry le site de production
100% inspirées de la nature qu'on a
développée ici un site 100% inspiré la
nature ça veut dire quoi c'est un site
on a créé des boucles circulaire
comprend des déchets et avec ses déchets
on vient produire des aliments de
qualité par exemple on prend du marc de
café du carton et avec ça on bien
produire des champignons de qualité où
on vient prendre des biodéchets des
restes cantine et autres et grâce à ça
on va venir produire des fruits et
légumes de qualité très grande
satisfaction de voir qu'on peut penser à
la fois alimentation saine circuits
courts et réinsertion sociale
donc c'est vraiment l'ensemble
des compétences qu'on souhaite
développer dans notre pays qui sont
rassemblés dans cet établissement porter
un projet porté un projet de réinsertion
sociale porter un projet de territoire
et porter un projet aussi qui innovent
quelque part pour une agriculture
moderne pour une agriculture qui
s'échappe un peu d des sentiers battus
et on a besoin parfois d'avoir aussi
cette cette image d'une agriculture qui
aujourd'hui est bien aux prendre des
chemins de traverse pour aller faire des
expérimentations particulière dans
l'actualité du jour bien sûr les
commémorations des attentats du 13
novembre il ya tout juste deux ans les
attaque faisait 130 morts et en ce jour
de souvenir les députés étaient formés
cet après midi aux gestes et
comportements qui sauve des vies
une formation assurée par la brigade des
sapeurs-pompiers de paris à l'assemblée
nationale
c'est une initiative lancée par béatrice
piron député la république en marche de
la 3e circonscription des yvelines
ce type de formation a été développée au
suite aux attentats de 2015 seulement
40% des français et maîtrisent ces
gestes de premiers secours
on accueille sur ce plateau notre
première invitée docteur tayeb ferradji
bonsoir ne soit vous êtes le chef de
pôle du secteur 78,04 de psychiatrie
infanto-juvénile c'est au centre
hospitalier jean-martin-charcot de
plaisir le secteur couvre tout le sud
des yvelines on précise alors avec
l'association cassiopée et l'hôpital
charcot vous organisé demain un colloque
au théâtre de fontenay le fleury ça
s'appelle vulnérabilité et résilience
une journée dédiée à la question de
l'enfant et de la famille en présence de
nombreux spécialistes venus du monde
entier on va en parler dans un instant
c'est un colloque qui s'adresse en fait
à toutes les personnes qui travaillent
avec avec les enfants oui un tous les
professionnels du chant de l'enfance de
la petite enfance jusqu'aux ados donc
qu'ils soient du monde sanitaire social
ou éducatif en fait une forme de
convergence sur des thématiques qui nous
portons tous ses sens va passer de
plusieurs domaines social éducatif
médical aussi c'est absolument
absolument les conférenciers vont
essayer d'aborder toutes ces
questionnaires chacun à partir de son
expertise
alors c'est le deuxième colloque qui est
organisé par votre secteur le premier
avait eu lieu il y a deux ans et avait
aussi pour thème central la famille
c'est ça oui bien sûr parce que autour
de l'enfance et la famille le noyau
central c'est la famille donc il nous
paraissait tout à fait normal et
légitime d'avoir une réflexion autour de
la cellule familiale avec tout ce que ça
implique comme enjeu qu'il soit
sanitaires qu'ils soient éducative
qu'ils soient sociaux on voit d'ailleurs
les images de ce premier colloque
c'était il ya deux ans au théâtre de
fontaines fleuries est là pourquoi
pourquoi consacrer ce deuxième colloque
plus à l'enfant en ligne est toujours la
thématique de la famille mais on va
parler de plus fin plus particulièrement
de l'enfant pour ce deuxième colloque
parce que nous nous sommes des
professionnels de l'enfance et de
l'adolescence dont il allait de soi que
nous voulons aussi partager nos
préoccupations avec tous ceux que ça
intéresse et il était tout à fait normal
que la réflexion initiée il ya deux ans
continue sur d'autres thèmes parce qu'il
ya deux ans ce n'était pas du tout les
mêmes thèmes qu'ils étaient amarrés
et maintenant on continue à explorer
d'autres aspects du champ de l'enfance
et de l'adolescence vulnérabilité et
résilience c'est le nom de ce colloque
on imagine donc l'enfant fragile
vulnérable mais se pose aussi la
question de sa capacité à faire face à
des situations difficiles
absolument alain fois celle de l'enfant
mais celle aussi de des parents de la
société parce que ça se joue à
différents niveaux
donc comment développer des outils qui
paraît qu'ils vont permettre à chaque
professionnel quel que soit son champ de
compétence de
d'accompagner au mieux les enfants dont
nous avons la charge et notamment cette
question elle sera abordée demain en ce
jour là des attentats du 13 novembre
c'est comment accompagner les victimes
des attentats c'est l'une des guerres
matic à la fois cette question là mais
aussi nous avons aussi une réflexion
importante sur comment on en arrive là
notamment à l'adolescence la question de
la radicalisation sur la concerne la
radicalisation et de la vulnérabilité
inhérente justement à ce type de
mouvement alors la journée va
s'articuler autour de quatre temps forts
quatre séances avec plusieurs plusieurs
conférenciers qui veulent seulement
intervenir absolument donc on a des
conférenciers qui viennent du canada
d'italie de belgique et de france bien
sûr et on souhaite donc profité de leur
présence pour pour un peu bénéficier de
leur expérience de leur éclairage et
puis confronté un peu les modèles parce
que les anglo saxons on travaille pas du
tout comme nous d'accord et puis les
italiens sont pas du tout au même point
que nous donc c'est aussi un moment pour
pour confronter nos expériences et
pouvoir réfléchir à d'autres façons de
travailler si besoin vous parler des
grands spécialistes spécial italien je
crois alors j'ai pu le programme sous
les yeux mais il ya le professeur on a
dit amaury cheli qui interviendra un
filet de voix laquelle on est professeur
de psychologie à la faculté de parme et
qui s'occupe notamment de toutes les
mamans et des bébés qui arrive vous
savez tous les drames qui se passe en
méditerranée ce dernier mois ces trois
dernières années
donc elle travaille énormément avec la
croix rouge italienne sur l'accueil des
tout petits et de leurs mamans
elle va nous restituer un peu son
expérience dans ce domaine plusieurs
autres noms à retrouver demain derrière
questions qu'elles sont finalement les
objectifs d'art qu'est ce que vous
espérez de ce colloque
ce que ce que ce que nous souhaitons
c'est d'abord apporter au plus près des
professionnels du département et du
territoire une expertise et des
expériences auxquelles un certain nombre
d'entre eux n'auraient pas accès
autrement et et puis
aménagée comme ça l'espace d'une journée
un moment de convivialité des changes de
réflexion qui sont de nature à
encourager le travail dès qu'ils parlent
encourager
l'investissement des professionnels qui
travaillent sur eux sur le territoire et
puis éventuellement à leur donner des
idées de formation de spécialisation de
travail merci à vous docteur alain
faradji et moitié moins massif chefs de
pôles secteur 78,04 de psychiatrie
infanto juvénile au centre hospitalier
jean-martin-charcot de plaisir vous
organisez donc demain ce colloque autour
de la question de l'enfant et de la
famille vulnérabilité et résilience et
ça se passe au théâtre de fontenay le
fleury loose novembre 1918 été signé à
l'armistice à rethondes m qui met fin
bien sûr à la première guerre mondiale
qui a mis fin à la première guerre
mondiale c'est un conflit qui a fait
plus de 18 millions de morts
samedi c'était 99e anniversaire de cet
armistice et parmi les cérémonies à
saint quentin en yvelines
la mairie de maurepas a donné une grande
place aux enfants de l'école mal me
donne façon concrète pour les
enseignants de leur apprendre
l'importance du devoir de mémoire
marylène iapichino nicolas kirillovitch
et les arènes
[Musique]
samedi la ville de moore pas convié ses
habitants à commémorer l'armistice
la cérémonie s'est déroulée en deux
temps avec d'abord un premier passage au
cimetière pour fleurir les tombes
[Musique]
le cortège s'est ensuite rendu au
monument aux morts le maire a fait un
discours après avoir laissé son pupitre
aux élèves de cm2 de l'école élémentaire
mal me donne le soir il faut dedans
[Musique]
nous avons travaillé sur les lettres de
soldat poilus suite à une intervention
d'une association d'anciens combattants
qui est venu par leur parler de la
première guerre mondiale
ils ont bon répondu donc aux questions
des enfants
l'école s'est impliqué dans le cadre du
devoir de mémoire et les enfants se sont
largement investis dans cette cérémonie
tous les ans les enfants participent ils
sont très impliqués on le voit
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui puisque beaucoup
d'entre eux ont appris par coeur donc
ils ont mis du coeur z'amis du temps et
de l'énergie
ce qui prouve que finalement ils sont
très attentifs aussi à ce devoir de
mémoire et j'en suis ravi plus qu'une
lecture de lettres
les écoliers ont largement pris part à
la commémoration chacun a déposé une
rose blanche au pied du monument et a
interprété plusieurs chants une
cérémonie qu'ils garderont en mémoire
et pour entretenir ce devoir de mémoire
ces deux personnes se mobilisent avec
mon plateau pascal mathieu et patricia
poulard bonsoir mesdames vous êtes vous
deux et deux autres à nîmes antenne qui
ne sont pas là ce soir avec deux autres
il y monte vous avez mené des recherches
sur 26 poilus combattants donc de la
première guerre mondiale dont le nom est
inscrit sur le monument aux morts de
montigny le bretonneux ce travail vient
d'être publiée sur le site wiki de la
grande guerre qui est mise en place par
le conseil départemental des yvelines et
les archives départementales des
yvelines également première question
pourquoi se lancer dans cette démarche
on va commencer avec vous pascal mathieu
et bien ce sont les archives des
yvelines qui sont à l'origine de notre
démarche avec la présentation d'un site
qui s'appelle le wiki 14 18 qui nous a
été présenté nous avons pu faire un
atelier aussi de prise en main de cet
outil et ça concernait donc la guerre de
14 et nous avions décidé au début de
parler du monument de montigny parce
qu'il n'y avait à ce moment là pas de
d'articles sur notre ville
et puis le projet a évolué et nous avons
décidé finalement de nous occuper de
nous polluer de leur donner un petit peu
de vie et vous alors pourquoi vous êtes
rejoint finalement à cette initiative
aussi qu'est-ce-qui qu'est-ce qui vous
plaisait qu'est-ce qui vous qu'est ce
que vous vouliez faire mettre en avant
dans cette initiative
j'ai assisté au même préparation que
pascal et j'invite montigné depuis 1970
donc c'est une ville qui me tient à
coeur donc partir sur nos points de vue
c'est important on le voit dans qu'on a
vu dans le sujet précédent sur mort pas
là le devant démence et c'est important
de l'entretenir de ne pas oublier le nom
de ceux qui sont la france le nom sur le
monument sébile mais bon on a pensé que
c'était bien aussi de redonner un petit
peu de vie est on avec nous donc
françoise penchard aussi qui a nous a
beaucoup aidés et claudine adroit qui
elle avait travaillé avec ces collégiens
sur le sujet donc on a vraiment
travaillé à 4 de façon très intéressante
en triant classe en organisant en
recherchant tout ce qu'on pouvait sur
ces poilus et il nous en manque encore
d'autres choses nous en manquons
libération fin d'entretien vous êtes de
formation historienne non pas du tout
c'est à dire non moi je suis enfin nous
nous sommes enseignants toutes les deux
et c'est quand même la généalogie un qui
nous allons dans les archives et voilà
de l'aca s'est ouvert un tout un tas de
d'activités passionnantes et quand on
veut mener un tel travail de recherche
on s'y prend commencé c'est quoi les
étapes finalement pour mener ce travail
aller jusqu'au monument aux morts déjà
faire des photos effectivement et puis
après aller à la recherche dans les
archives au niveau des recensements de
l'état civil
[Musique]
vij matricule douala des fiches
matricule changer aussi de départements
quand nos poilus des ni ailleurs voilà
c'est tout un travail de fourmi un petit
peu moins selon vous aimons bien faire
et qui n'est pas terminée ç'a pris
combien de temps pour faire ce travail
une année on a mis du temps a mis du
temps mais nous faisons ça est notre
notre sur le temps libre
oui donc à raison j'avais lu le verdict
c'est à raison d'une séance à peu près
par semaine il ya le ramener à trois ou
à quatre selon les jours et les
disponibilités de chacune et avec l'aide
de catherine blanchard des yvelines sur
l'outil wiki parce que c'était quand
même pas facile de le maîtriser au début
et le travail qui vient d'être publié si
j'ai pas de bêtises tu es vendredi qu'il
a été publié ce travail il faut
l'oublier depuis déjà un moment donc on
peut le consulter facilement sur je peux
donner le cycle est le site we équipe ça
qui sera sûrement aussi pour nos
téléspectateurs il s'affiche
actuellement à l'eysée wiki 14 18 points
yvelines point fr alors vous êtes
répartis du coude et sur les 26 mon
poilu entre
vous éviterez les quatre personnes c'est
ça oui on s'est réparti mais on a
travaillé ensemble aussi en avait une
qui lisez ce que ce qui avait été trouvé
sur les poilus et puis l'autre qui
tapait
et donc tous ces faits est vrai au
niveau des recherches c'était un peu
compliqué quelquefois donc même si l'une
d'entre nous prenez en charge un poilu
les autres chercher aussi épique au vol
voilà on recroise et nono découverte et
qu'est ce que vous avez pu découvrir
alors justement on va faire un petit
tour de table
il nous reste une minute qu'est ce que
vous avez pu découvrir des thés des
choses intéressantes forcément mais
qu'est ce que vous voulez mettre en
avant commencez par vous à pascal et
bien d'abord le l'histoire du village de
montigny parce que plusieurs de ces
poilus était employée à la ferme de du
manet voilà donc on a découvert cette
ferme les métiers l'histoire de cette
ferme et voilà ils étaient au moins je
crois c'est 505 et on a reconstitué sa
grâce au recensement puisqu'on les a
trouvés sur le sur la liste des
personnes vivant à la ferme
et puis je vais tester pour les deux
frères aussi peut-être enfin oui l'hôtel
offrira il est tant de frères et moi
latin qui sont tous les deux sont tous
les deux décédés pendant cette guerre
voilà et donc le week-end
il ya quinze jours maintenant nous
sommes vous allez faire un petit tour à
verdun et nous avons déposé des gerbes
sur
les monuments ou son or certains de ces
poilus justement très bien donc 5 de
montigny qui sont décédés à bas et dans
la continuité
madame a droit qui n'est pas là soit on
proposera probablement le portrait de
son grand père oui un poilu méthyle
bienvenue par contre très bien mais en
tout cas on vous félicite pour ce
travail de recherche
merci beaucoup à vous deux passes jan
michael et patricia pour l'armée
semaines et donc je rappelle et des
recherches sur 26 poilus de
montigny-le-bretonneux leurs noms sont
inscrits sur ce monument aux morts et on
peut retrouver un ses recherches sur le
site wiki 14-18 point fr économie c'est
le rendez vous des entreprises du
territoire organisée par la cci
versailles yvelines chambre de commerce
et d'industrie la quatrième édition des
smart bay se tenait vendredi dans les
locaux de bouygues construction a dû en
cours est la journée a mis à l'honneur
de technologies de l'industrie du futur
c'est la réalité augmentée et
l'impression 3d reportage doré longue
des rendez vous d'affaires individuels
qui côtoient des technologies très
futuriste lors de cette manifestation
annuelle consacrée à l'innovation en
plus de nouer de nombreux contacts avec
des partenaires les entreprises
yvelinoise ont notamment pu découvrir
les opportunités qu'offre l'impression
3d l'impression 3d permet la production
de masse de pièces sur mesure et on n'a
pas tous le même fémur on n'a pas tous
le même crâne et donc l'impression 3d à
une débouché naturel sur l'environnement
médical mais pas que parce que toutes
les industries aujourd'hui nous
sollicitent à travers l'europe est
également aux états unis en asie
autre technologie qui envahit notre
quotidien depuis ces dernières années la
réalité augmentée un procédé développé
notamment à elancourt dans les locaux
d'airbus defence and space on va venir
ajouter des informations digitales à
votre réalité qu'on va venir pointer des
objets et leur indiquer leur nature
on a présenté un petit peu ce qu'on a
fait autour d'une application qui est
l'un des premiers cas d'utilisation dans
le monde d'une éducation comment
utiliser la réalité augmentée pour
améliorer nos capacités dans le cadre du
training l'information guider les
entreprises yvelinoise pour qu'elles
s'approprient ces nouvelles technologies
numériques
c'était la volonté de la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie dans les
yvelines 14,1 pour cent des emplois sur
les à l'industrie contre 12,3 au niveau
au niveau national et seulement 7,6 au
niveau de toute la région ile de france
est donc c'était aussi une bonne raison
de mettre l'accent sur l'industrie et
l'industrie du futur des entreprises qui
ont pu également découvrir un nouveau
dispositif open connect lab destiné à
mieux développer leurs innovations le
sport samedi soir la boxe était à
l'honneur au vélodrome national avec le
mail et 24 une première dans l'enceinte
saint-quentinoise et en point d'orgue de
cet événement le combat de l'élan
courtois dila mohammadi qui défendait sa
ceinture européenne des poids super
moyens retour sur cette soirée avec
nicolas landry et nicolas kirilow liszt
montrer sous artifices pour un combat
explosif
l'élan courtois a dit la môme a dit
était très attendue pour ce gala de boxe
organisé au vélodrome nationale à
domicile le boxeur de 37 ans n'a pas
déçu ses supporters face à un adversaire
solide le champion en titre a dû livrer
un combat acharné pour remporter la
victoire
une victoire finalement acquise au plan
après la limite et qui lui permet de
conserver son titre de champion d'europe
dans la catégorie des poids super moyens
[Musique]
la chanson danse dans les yvelines
grande fierté et encore merci pour ceux
qui me soutiennent fierté un objectif
terminer on est parti pour d'autres
objectifs ou encore le monde à domicile
le champion d'europe a bénéficié d'un
soutien sans faille de ses proches
encouragements écrit ils étaient plus
d'une cinquantaine présents autour du
ring et y avoir beaucoup que ça rend
face christophe était présent ce soir et
nous importe aujourd'hui c'est et kadima
et garde sa ceinture et la veille je le
remercie c'est quelqu'un de courageux on
retient une belle du cordat dit là
c'était un beau combat ce soir et je
pense que tout le monde apprécie il
boxait eux aussi à domicile les membres
de la team phare au jihad et l'on court
termine avec un bilan positif
marvin petit a décroché une 22e victoire
en poids super-légers gallus coulon a
remporté lui sa huitième victoire chez
les super légers est vraiment une
dizaine belle salle le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et ça fait
vraiment plaisir de boxer chez nous
devant notre public on a je pense qu'on
était tous transcender quelques bords de
boxe ici
seul bémol de la soirée la défaite aux
points de marine tollé pour son premier
combat professionnel
au total pour ce premier gala de boxe
organisé au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines 12 combats étaient
organisées durant toute la soirée de
quoi satisfaire les 6000 spectateurs
c'est un bel endroit je pense progrès ce
type dans le monde
structure c'est top il n'y a pas de gros
événements qui se passent au vélodrome
des événements sportifs donc là c'est
vraiment une belle événements il faut
que ça continue sans comment changement
de style et et changement d'ambiance le
week-end prochain le vélodrome national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueillera
le championnat de france seniors de judo
mais je vous en parlais tout à l'heure
deux ans jour pour jour qui ont été
perpétrés les attentats de paris et de
saint denis et cet événement était en
faveur de l'association française des
victimes du terrorisme le deuxième
festival play for humanity il se
déroulait vendredi et samedi au scarabée
à la verrière de soirée concert avec une
dizaine de groupes à la fiche dont les
yvelinois de baby qui explique au micro
de nicolas d'ambri pourquoi ils ont
participé au festival c'est toujours un
truc caritative quelle que soit la cause
c'est plutôt plutôt bien de faire ça là
en plus n'est touché parce qu'on sait ce
qui s'est passé il ya deux ans c'était
surtout des salles de concert qu'avait
été touchés fin surtout en trop
et en plus nous on le fait sur deux
dates puisqu'on aura une autre à paris
et l'a personnellement je sais qu'on est
un peu le groupe local donc on n'a que
peu de kilomètres à faire pour soutenir
la chose c'est plutôt pas mal quand même
on leur a qu on leur a rien coûté puis
nous ont contribué à remplir la salle à
notre notre humble niveau
à notre humble niveau avant de refermer
ce journal on part à la découverte d'une
véritable caverne aux trésors sauf qu'à
la place ce sont des doudous une jeune
entrepreneuse a créé un site internet
qui propose aux parents plus de 7000
références de peluches opportunité pour
remplacer les doudous perdus par les
enfants
marylène yapi chinois lapinous pompon
winnie le doudou est le compagnon des
enfants alors si par malheur il vient à
disparaître
catastrophe pour éviter le drame julie
colo a créé deux du malin un site
internet de vente de doudou avec 7500
références différentes
en fait c'est une de mes nièces qu'avait
son doudou qui était absolument
pitoyable dans un état plus que foutu et
en fait je voulais lui faire la surprise
de lui remplacé donc j'ai fait toutes
les boutiques tous les magasins du coin
et je n'ai rien trouvé
sauf sur internet à 50 euros quoi le
doudou alors du coup comme je faisais
beaucoup les brocantes et les vide
greniers
j'ai commencé à en collecter quelques
uns et puis petit à petit le stock a
grossi et doudou malheur est arrivé en
elle charge une société spécialisée de
lui créer son site
mais pour le reste elle s'occupe de tout
sous le regard de ses compagnons elle
prépare l'expédition des derniers adopté
ils sont parfois en route pour l'autre
côté du globe
hier j'en voyais pour l'australie là
aujourd'hui a un paquet pour la belgique
un autre pour les pays bas
quant aux nouveaux arrivants qui
viennent de rejoindre le stock
il passe d'abord sous le feu des
projecteurs avec entre 700 et 1000
ventes par mois doudou malin pour
ambition de devenir le site numéro un du
doudou perdu et pour ceux dont le doudou
est rare on a pensé à tout donc on a une
alerte email vous pouvez vous inscrire
et en fait des cons en rentrant vous
avez une alerte ambitieux et motivés
avec son site gili colo a déjà remporté
le prix 100 jours pour entreprendre en
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal il est
disponible en replay sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
78 très bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]